did you read that thing that thing about
how to bow for when you're for what
you're trying to do it was like I think
it was on the plane they saw I read the
whole thing they discerned about a
degree for what you mean for when you
bow
she basically [ __ ] sucked her big toe
oh [ __ ] yeah like if someone's your
senior
you're supposed to be lower than they do
and they like this on this year and this
is you have to watching the whole time
call this the biggest cakes in Japan
god damn look at that what hi you're gay
hahaha
this bottom 10 turn turn turn
like we don't have much time at all so
let's just eat around here
there's a lot of shadow places around
here let's just go eat something and
then you guys need something and then
get on your way
I haven't at McDonald's here yet was it
good this is where toggle bell boys just
Taco Bell did you know when you walk up
some McDonald's delivery guy do you see
that [ __ ]
here's I'm not taking the pitch I'm
videoing him he's staring right at me oh
this is a nail picture it's too late we
have a plan bla woes Jawad oh I don't
know what a flam bla is but a sound fan
fan and you gotta pick your better cone
right now cappuccino bar can you tell us
what you got in that bag my trick oh oh
all day can you tell the farm viewers
what neighborhood how much you pay for
that
Michael Michael this looks like your
part of town the red-light district
I'm gonna take Josh on with me we're not
gonna get some food
you're not staying off [ __ ] Mike don't
lie you're such a [ __ ] liar
place whole place is on crack what is
going on I have no pupils all right
let's go to the elevator of [ __ ] doom
what is going on dude I'm tripping out
right now this is like really this is
really crazy looking I win this all day
the door opens well if you have epilepsy
you're screwed
I want my house to be like this if my
house is not this by the time I'm 35 I'm
going to kill myself I now know what I
want my place to look like for real you
know jump if you came into my house and
you're like David boom and you open the
door you'd be like what I'm living here
I want to live like I'm a fabulous [ __ ]
fabula welcome stupid [ __ ] to my home
ha ha ha ha here we have the peasants as
they first come to live in my place now
sit down this was made from exotic bald
eagle only two exist I killed both of
them ah ha ha ha this was a real tiger
before I skinned it killed it digitally
bred to put it on the screen you can run
with the jacket sit down and do push-ups
think about it oh [ __ ] I'm rich young
Anthony I see you come to my house and
you've brought your wife I'll leave her
I'll give you 7 more
haha I'm kidding I joke she is not
replaceable but seriously talk to me
later see what happens as you can see we
have a little Mexican boy he will serve
you whatever you like please dance for
our guests
show her a great time dance for her
that's funny he can see jokes at your
back would you get dinner
why do we have grass on fire there's not
a real grass
lots more explosions I don't know what
ethnicity she is
what the [ __ ] that we just witnessed
dude I don't know what the [ __ ] is going
on but it's just crazy like I don't the
[ __ ] going on that's insane dude cause
dinosaurs are crazy the costumes is
[ __ ] machine like a dinosaur on
dinosaur of the char I think one of them
lightning all special touch me I don't
know I don't know I mean it was so
entertaining but I was like my mind just
can't process everything just yeah I
don't know what the [ __ ] is with this
but I know Joe would absolutely love
this and I feel like that's what
everybody was that's the first thing I
thought - I like this is Joe [ __ ] yeah
Joe would have been like I get it I get
[ __ ] they're having this show was that
Dee's that one dude on the horse like I
like that show what did you think about
it
I sure was [ __ ] crazy I can picture
you may get that shoulder ha ha ha right
oh no I know Billman perfect addition to
this
Oh